So I want to take up in Volume 10 and December the 21st, 1911.
So the divine will is called a sun.
And the reason for that is that the sun is the source of light for us on the earth,
and the divine will is God who is light.
So one John, one, five.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus came for just a little while."
And placing himself in front of me, he looked at me all over.
Now, those gazes penetrated me inside and out, and I became all light.
Now, put beside that Mark 10, 21, that Jesus gazed at the young man.
Do you remember if the rich young man, he really gazed, and his gaze actually penetrates you.
Now, Louisa's in a very high state of union with God, and so that gaze, she said,
"I became all light," so she was infused with this light.
And the more he looked at me, the more I sparkled, she said.
And through this light, he looked at the whole world.
Okay, so Louisa is the channel through which he is actually viewing the world.
Now, if he looks at the world through Louisa, he's taking the best possible view.
Can you get it?
Because she's the one who loves him the most.
She's the one who cooperates the most with him, so he will have more desire to have compassion
on the rest of us.
But if he looked at the world through the eyes and the heart of a great sinner, the only
stimulus he would have would be justice.
So the stimulus he will have looking through Louisa is compassion.
Then after fixing on me thoroughly, he told me, "My daughter, my will is like a sun."
Because Jesus himself is the light, John A12.
And one who lives in my volition, now to live in my volition is very different from making
a few acts in the divine will, it's 24/7, 365.
One who lives in my volition becomes a sun and only through this sun do I look at the
world and pour graces and benefits for the good of all.
If there wasn't this sun of my will in a few souls, the earth would become foreign to me.
Now, in other words, there's got to be a little bit of light on the earth, otherwise it's
total darkness.
So beside that, I want you to put Matthew 5, 14, that your light must shine so that everybody
will see it and give glory to the Father.
So he said, "If there wasn't a divine will operating in a few souls, the whole earth would
be dark.
And I would sever any communication between the earth and heaven because there's no compatibility
between light and darkness.
No compatibility between heaven and hell."
And darkness in the scriptures and in these writings represents hell.
Light represents God.
So the soul who does my will perfectly is like the sun in the world.
With this difference that the material sun does good, giving light and material good.
In other words, it helps all the flowers to grow and helps all everybody to feel good.
And the sun of my will in the soul impotrates both spiritual and temporal graces and gives
light to souls as John 9.5, anyone who walks with me will be walking in the light.
Okay.
So the divine will operating inside of us not only gives light to people all around us,
but it also intercedes for everyone.
My daughter, let my will be that which you cherish the most.
May my will be your life, your all, even in the holiest things and even in my very privation.
Louisa will get better and better at this as she goes along.
You certainly will not give me the sorrow of moving away from my will, even for just
a little, would you?
So Louisa said, "I remain chanted and you disappeared."
And I'm thinking to myself, what do these words of Jesus actually mean?
Maybe he wants something big of me, he's absolutely right.
We're just about to go into volume 11 and he's going to make the revelation of the divine
will to her.
So January the 5th, 1912, Jesus renders himself the debtor of the soul and we have the effects
of continuous prayer.
Having read in my writings that when blessed Jesus deprives of himself, he becomes our debtor.
We're reading volume 10 and that is in volume 4, as far as I can remember.
We just put volume 4 in the margin there.
So notice that Louisa is reading her own writings.
Why would she have to do that?
She has to do that in order to correct any mistakes.
He has to do that to try and answer any questions that the priests have and all the rest of it.
Because anybody who writes a book has got to do their own editing of the material.
So he becomes our debtor.
I was thinking to myself, if Jesus counts all the privations and the huffs and the peaks
that I must take, especially in these times, who knows how many debts he has made with me?
But I fear as if my state is not his will, she's still at that in volume 10.
Instead of making him the debtor, I render myself the debtor.
So Jesus moved in my interior.
That's Luke 1721, "The Kingdom of God is within you."
And also one Corinthians 3 16, "No, you're not that you are the temple of the living God
and the spirit of God dwells in you."
So moving in my interior, he told me, "I'm really looking at what you do," he said,
"whether you shift, whether you change your way.
As long as you don't shift, be sure that I keep signing new debts.
You're waiting, your tolerance and your perseverance provide me with the bill on which I put my
signatures.
You'd never have that image of him, would you?
But if you don't do that, first, I would not know where to put my signatures.
Second, you'd have no document in hand to be able to collect the debts."
In other words, you wouldn't have any checkbook.
And if you wanted to be paid, I'd answer you, frankly, "I do not know you," wow.
So you shift out of my will and you've shifted.
Okay.
So that's Matthew 7, 23, "Lord, did we not work mighty miracles in your name?"
And he said, "I do not know you."
Now, why would he say, "I do not know you?"
If he says that, the person is outside of the divine will.
They're doing their own will.
Also Matthew 25, 12, "The ones whom he doesn't know don't end up in heaven," to put it mildly.
And then Jesus said to her, "You would remain confused.
It's true that I make myself the debtor when I deprive you of my presence or of sensible
grace."
And to put that in language you and I might understand is when you get a riddity and prayer,
this complete inability to pray.
Okay.
And you have to persevere regardless of how you feel.
But this, when my wisdom disposes so and they do not give me the occasion to deprive
them of me.
Now, to give the Lord the occasion of depriving him of us means you sin.
Because when we sin, he goes out.
Remember Hebrews 12, 14, melting on holy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
It's about that simple.
But when they do give me the occasion or when they are not faithful or they do not wait
for me, this one that we can fail in quite a lot, Isaiah 40, 31, "Those who wait upon
the Lord will renew their strength.
They shall mount up with wings like the eagle.
They shall run and not be weary and walk and not faint."
Isaiah 40, 31.
So the ones who won't wait for me, that means at this very moment I'm not able to pray,
I get up and I go, but don't wait.
After I deprive myself of them, then instead of me becoming their debtor, they're the ones
who make themselves the debtors.
If I make a debt, I have something from which to pay.
And I remain always what I am, he's God.
But if you do it, he said, "How would you pay me?"
Do you remember the unforgiving debtor?
Matthew 18, 21, to 35, there was no way he could repay the debt, could he?
And there was no way that we can repay our debts either.
Therefore, he says, "Be attentive at your place, in your state of victim, in whatever
way I keep you, if you want to make me, your debtor."
Okay.
So Louisa said to him, "Who knows Jesus how the priest is doing, since he's not feeling
well.
Today I have not remembered him continuously before you."
Now look at that, when she's told to pray for somebody, she does it continuously.
Sometimes when people ask us to pray for them, you might pray once, and then think, "Will
I pray for you?"
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, she will keep it up.
She said, "As I did the day before yesterday," and then Jesus said, "He keeps feeling more
relieved because," I've watched this now, "this is fantastic," because when you pray
me continuously, I feel the strength of the prayer, and it almost prevents me from making
him feel more suffering, noticeably almost.
That means I'm not going to heal him, he needs a bit of suffering.
But if you keep praying, then the whole thing is mitigated, okay?
With time, as this continuous prayer ceases, he said, "This strength keeps dissolving,
and I'm left free to make him suffer more."
I loved that.
Sorry for laughing, and I noticed that too many of you are laughing.
I think it's brilliant because what the Lord is saying is there are times when you need
suffering.
You don't want it, but you actually need it.
You don't know you need it, he knows it, and he will send suffering to you in order to
accomplish that thing of getting you out of wherever you are and on a little bit further
in the journey of union to him.
But if somebody prays for healing, they're blocking the thing, and you still have this
debt.
It's very interesting, it's something we can discuss later, because many people misunderstand
praying for healing.
And the Catholic way is actually the correct way if it be God's will.
Catholics always added that it was the Protestant influence that said, "I command heal it,
the big me," but the Catholics always added, "If it be God's will," because the Protestants
don't accept the cross we do.
They don't accept that God sends you the crosses in order to purify you and sanctify you, and
they consider any suffering and any cross to be an evil.
This is where we are very, very different in our approach to spirituality.
So obviously, this priest needed a bit of purification, and Jesus says, "When you get
tired praying, I let him have the suffering."
It's very interesting.
But notice how sensitive the Lord is to our prayer.
As long as the prayer is kept up, he won't let the suffering.
In other words, he will actually hear you, and for love of you, he gives the priest time
out.
It's very interesting.
You need to remember that when people are ill, that we pray for their comfort and that
they can relact into accepting what God wants to do and bring them through and to pray them
through the journey rather than take them away from what God is doing.
I don't know if I'm talking since, but we can discuss it later.
So January the 11th, 1912 is about love.
After I received communion, my beloved Jesus made himself seen all around me, and I was
in the middle as if within a flow.
Jesus was the flow.
She's the little thing in the river.
Jesus is the river.
He's the flow.
And I did nothing which was in the middle of the flow.
Now notice my nothingness in your allness.
We say it in our morning prayer, don't we?
Now who can say what I experienced in this flow?
I felt I was immense because she's in him.
Yet nothing existed of me but nothingness.
There's my nothingness in your allness.
And what she's saying here is that this is your greatest position of power.
So it's 2 Corinthians 12, 9.
My power works best in weakness.
The Lord doesn't mind us having weaknesses as long as we just let His power work with
us.
2 Corinthians 12, 9.
So I felt I was immense, she said, yet nothing existed of me but nothingness.
I felt breathed upon by Jesus.
Now Jesus breathed upon the apostles in John 20 verses 22 and 23.
And His breathing upon them made them a living church.
That's John 20 verses 22 and 23.
I felt breathed upon by Jesus.
I felt His breath around me and everywhere.
But I don't have the words to express myself I'm too ignorant.
I wrote this to obey, she said, then afterwards Jesus told me, my daughter, see how much I
love you and how I keep you safe within my flow.
In other words, you are completely surrounded by me.
I keep you within me and this is how you should keep me safe and sheltered within you.
Now that's John 14, 20 to 21, you and me and I and you, both completely one, both flowing
into each other.
So this is how you should keep me as John 14, John 14, 20 to 21.
Love wants to be matched by love.
Now Saint John of the Cross says love can be repaid by love alone.
Now you know yourselves that if a parent gives everything material to a child but doesn't
love them, they will have a very dysfunctional person on their hands because the only thing
that keeps us healthy and safe and able to grow is love, there's nothing else.
Okay, but I want you to notice that love wants to be matched by love.
There are two capitals there.
That's divine love in us, that's we're living at the divine level, wants to be matched by
divine love, which is divine and you can see it the other way around.
God's divine love wants to be matched by his own love in us.
So as to have contentment in making a greater surprise of love.
Therefore, never go out from within my love, from within my desires, and from within my
works and from within my all.
That's John 15, nine, as the Father has loved me, so I have loved you.
That's also Deuteronomy six, four to ten, that's John 15, nine and Deuteronomy six, four
to ten.
So to put that very simply, if love, if God's love is to be matched by me, then I need his
love.
My love is useless, it's too small, does that make sense?
It's far too small, so I have to fuse myself into the divine will, enter into him, take
his love and love him with his own love, is that okay, you can do it, but it can only
be matched by his own love, but just make sure that you fuse and you take his love and
then love you, until you adore him with his own iterations and you bless him with his
own blessings and so on and so forth.
So January the 19th, 1912 is about the union between us and God.
As I was in my usual state, my beloved Jesus made himself seen with a little rope in his
hand and with it, he kept binding hearts, clasping them very tightly to himself.
In such a way as to make them lose their own feeling and make them feel the whole of Jesus.
Now the word feeling is being used, look at this, I'm scratching my finger, okay, feelings
are a very, very superficial thing and feelings go up and down.
She's actually saying something deeper than that, it's the translator that's giving us
a problem, okay.
She says that Jesus had a little rope in his hand and he kept binding hearts, clasping them
very tightly to himself, so that they lose the sense of their own feeling.
That means they become more conscious of him and less conscious of themselves, it's actually
what he's trying to say because she's talking about self-awareness versus awareness of God.
And if you're reading books about contemplation, one of the things, if you ask what is contemplation,
they will tell you it's an awareness of God, it's an awareness of God.
Whether you're actually praying or not praying, you have this awareness of God.
So they lose their own self-awareness and they become more aware of his presence and
his love.
And feeling themselves so clasped, their hearts wriggled about and as they wriggled about
the knot which Jesus had made over them loosened as they feared, that it was a detriment to
them to no longer feel themselves.
Now some people who don't understand contemplation, don't understand this union with God, think
that as they are drawn into this incredible union with God that they're losing their self-awareness
and they're losing their control and they're resisting and enormous grace is really sad.
All afflicted because of the behavior, Jesus said, "My daughter, have you seen how souls
render my tenderness, not tenderness, s of love in vain?
I keep binding hearts to unite them closely with me, to make them lose all that is human.
And instead of letting me do it, seeing that they're human, they're human being broken."
Now I'll explain this in a minute, they lose air, they struggle, they wriggle about and
also they want to look a little bit themselves at how cold, dry or warm they are, okay.
Now when the Lord is drawing us to himself, this kind of experience that is being spoken
about here, you'd get it more when you're in prayer than out of prayer, is that okay?
And the Lord tries to draw you out of just being a human, estimating everything according
to how I feel.
And he tries to draw you into recognizing him, recognizing his presence, recognizing his
love, therefore he pulls you away from your selfishness and your self-awareness and what's
in it for me and all the rest of it, and he tries to pull you gently towards reaching
out to him and reaching out to love.
And so there will be, the ego has to let go for love to actually rise.
And when that process is completed, some people take them all their lives, some people can
do it quickly.
But when the ego actually lets go, divine love is born.
It's literally a resurrection moment, and he will talk about that again.
It's an incredible resurrection moment.
And so you become aware of him, unless aware of everything that's for yourself.
I remember talking to somebody, and I know a few people like this in fact, and I said,
why aren't you wearing a coat, it's very cold today, and they did this.
They looked at the arm and said, yeah, true, and continue talking.
Their awareness was not with the body, it was with the presence of the Lord.
And when they saw the goose pimples on the arm, they said, oh yes, truly, you're right.
The rest of us wouldn't wear that long to put the cardigan on, would we?
No, but it's just that the awareness has been drawn into a much, much deeper place.
And these people who are like that, have a very deep communion with God.
So the Lord is trying to bring us all there.
He doesn't love one person more than another, okay?
By looking at themselves, he said, and by wriggling about the knot I made becomes loose,
and they want to be with me at a distance.
That means they want to be in control.
Lots of people are like that, they have a little compartment in their heads for religion.
And then outside of that compartment, it's me, or it's the world, or it's my family,
or it's politics, or it's whatever it is.
But religion only has this one compartment, and so there's no way the Lord has this person's life.
There's no way that he is Lord of that person's life, no way at all.
And it's very difficult for that person to have a deep communion with God.
And it's only because they want to have control.
I remember hearing a comment many years ago from a priest, and he said,
"The last citadel that an intelligent man will give to his God is his intellect."
You want to be in control, you want to understand, you know?
And so we're like that.
We only want to give what we actually know and grasp, and we know the value of it.
We turned the penny over a few times to make sure that it really is only a penny,
do you know what I mean?
But the pounds are elsewhere, and so we can be very miserly in giving to God.
"They want to be with me at a distance," he said, "but not class, not class means in union.
In such a way they no longer feel themselves."
You see, because the person in union is thinking of the other one all the time.
"Okay, this afflicts me very much," he said, "and they prevent my games of love."
They do not think that, and do not think that these are only souls who are far away from me.
Rather, these are those who are all around you," she said.
In other words, they're priests and religious and people who think they know God.
"You will make them understand well the sorrow that they give to me,
and that if they do not let themselves be clasped by me to the point of losing the sense of themselves,
I will never be able to expand my graces and my carisms with them."
And then he said, "Do you understand?"
And she said, "Do you do, yeah?"
"Poor ones," de Wiese said, "if they understood the secret contained in your clasping,"
that clasping, she's actually using a word very similar to what's in the book of Genesis,
that a man must leave his father and mother and leave to his wife.
Now, that's the clasping of two and one.
Okay, so we understand it in terms of marriage.
So if I give you the marriage image, then you'll know what's being spoken about here,
and it's a very close union with God.
Okay, so if they understood the secret contained in this very close union with you,
she said, "They wouldn't do it, they would let you do what you want."
Even more, they themselves would make themselves smaller so as to let you tighten the knot.
Now, beside that, I wanted to put John 3.30.
"He must grow greater, and I must grow smaller."
Okay.
At that moment, Louisa said, "I made myself very small, and Jesus clasped me,
and instead of wriggling about, I let him squeeze me more tightly."
I called that squeeze a hard love.
And as he squeezed me, I felt the life of Jesus losing my own.
Now, what Jesus has done there, and he does this with her all the time,
because she's a woman who has no education.
So he keeps on giving her graphic images of what he has just said,
so that she can get it.
So he clasps her, and she feels herself getting smaller and becomes more aware of him.
And in describing this, she's trying to get us to understand what she's saying.
Oh, how happy I felt with the life of Jesus.
I was able to love more, and I could reach everything that Jesus wanted,
because this love was divine love.
So that's 1 Peter 5.5 to 9.
And Philippians 4, verses 13 and 19.
So January the 20th, 1912, we're talking about love again.
As my beloved Jesus returned, he continued to make himself seem while clasping hearts.
You see, very often messages just continue on from one, the other.
"And the souls resisted those squeezes," she said.
"Once they did, grace would remain inoperative."
Now, there I want to give you Matthew 25, verses 14 to 30.
That's the parable of the talents, and the fact that one person was given a talent,
and he did absolutely nothing about it.
Other people were active with what they were given, and one of them was not active.
So it's the inactive ones you have here.
"Grace would remain inoperative in the one who just wouldn't allow Jesus his freedom."
And Jesus would take the grace out of his hand and bring it to those few who were letting themselves be squeezed.
Okay?
Now, that's exactly what you get in the parable of the talents.
That was taken off the one who wouldn't use it and given it to the one who was the most active.
So he brought a good part of it to me.
She said, "Hi," because she's the most active.
On seeing this, I said to him, "My sweet life, you've been so good to me in letting me share in the grace which others refuse."
Yet I feel no squeezes on the contrary.
I feel so very wide, so much so that I am unable to see the width or the height or the depth of the boundaries in which I find myself.
It is the boundaries of divine will. It's infinite.
Okay, it's infinite.
And Jesus said to her, "My beloved daughter, my squeezes are felt by one who, letting herself be squeezed thoroughly by me, cannot enter to live in me."
If she doesn't let herself be squeezed by the Lord, then she can't enter into him.
But one who lets herself be squeezed by me as I want already passes into living with me.
There's your John 14, 20 again.
You also have Ephesians 2, 10, where God's work of art. And he keeps on saying, "If you don't let me work with you, you're not going to get anywhere."
Okay.
So the one who lets herself be squeezed by me as I want already passes into living in me.
By living in me, everything is whiteness. The constraints no longer exist.
That means you have this incredible sense of freedom.
All the constraint lasts for as long as the soul has the patience to let herself be squeezed by me to the point of undoing the human being in order to live in the divine life.
That means allowing the ego to really be put down so that the divine life can rise up.
But then as she passes into living in me, I keep her safe.
I let her wander throughout my endless boundaries. That is the endless boundaries of the divine will.
And I no longer need to use bonds on the contrary. Many times I myself have to force her so as to put her out a little.
Now, Louisa always complains when she's put out and she's sent back to her ordinary life. She complains loudly.
To let her see the evils of the earth and to make her plead would create her yearning for the salvation of my children.
So you can see that the reason why she's sent back from all these experiences out of the body is to go back and intercede for others.
So to have them spared the deserved chastisements.
And she's on tender hook and she pushes me and she wants to enter into me lamenting saying that the earth is not for her.
Now you've had that for ten volumes with Louisa.
How many times have I not done this with you? He said, "I had to show myself huffy and fussy." Now he's using her words.
"To make you stay a little bit at your place otherwise you would not have lasted one minute outside of me."
In other words, I had to use force on you to make you do it.
"My heart knows what I suffered in seeing you outside of me wriggling about struggling and crying.
While the others do this so as not to be squeezed, you do it so as to try and stay with me."
So there are two opposite ends of the scale.
And how many times have you yourself not become huffy and fussy because of this my way of operating?
Don't you remember that we've also been in a fight?
That's a little while earlier. She said, "Yes, I remember the day before yesterday." She said, "Precisely, I was about to get upset because you put me outside of yourself."
And as I saw you crying over the evils of the earth, I cried together with you and the huffyness went away.
"You are truly naughty, Jesus," she said. That's a very close relationship, isn't it?
Don't you know that you are a naughty, little naughty one? She said, "I put your naughty of love." It's okay.
"In order to give love and to receive love, you arrive at naughtiness." Isn't it true, Jesus?"
She said, "After a huff and a fuss that we take with each other and we love each other even more," and he said certainly certainly.
It's necessary to love, he said, "And we'd have to add the words in order to be able to understand love."
If you don't allow love's expression, how will you ever come across it?
And when love does not obtain the intent by good manners, it tries to obtain it with huffs and fusses and even holy naughtiness.
Now, those of you who are married probably understand that more than me.
Okay. So, January the 27th, 1912. This is Louisa wanting obscurity.
This morning, Jesus showed me a soul who was crying, but it seemed rather to be crying of love.
Jesus clasped her, and it seemed that inside his heart there was a cross,
which pressing against her heart made her feel abandonment, coldness, agony, distraction, oppression, and so on.
And the soul wriggled about, and a few times she escaped from the arms of Jesus to put herself at his feet.
That's a very interesting one, isn't it? Have you got it?
He's holding her very close to himself, and she wriggles out, gets down to his feet,
which means she's outside of his heart, and she thinks it's more religious to be at his feet,
whereas he had brought her into a much higher place.
That's us doing something, we don't understand what he's at, and we actually do the wrong thing.
So she escaped the arms of Jesus in order to put herself at her at his feet, which she taught was a more humble position,
and probably maybe her spiritual director told her that as well.
Jesus wanted that in her state she would hold on, remaining in his arms, telling her,
"If you are able to hold on in this state, remaining in my arms without wavering, this cross will be your sanctification.
Otherwise, you'll always stay at the same point."
Now, the rest of us know all about that, don't we?
Have you ever had an experience more than once?
And you said to yourself, "I have been round this round about before.
As long as you don't do the round about ten times, it isn't too bad."
But some people go round the round about so often that they actually see their own tracks.
And what they're doing is they're refusing to take the one and only decision to get off the roundabout.
That is, you have to take a decision to go forward.
And each one of us have decisions to take inside that nobody else knows about,
because even though in one sense we're all on the same journey, in another, every single one of us is on a different journey.
And there are decisions we have to take internally that if you don't do it, you'll send you round the roundabout to give you a chance to do it again.
Or as teachers say, "Don't repeat the exam ten times."
Once it's tolerable, not ten times.
And the awful thing is that you can get stuck. I've often met people who are completely stuck in the spiritual life.
They had gone so far, but there was a point they wouldn't shift through.
It's really very interesting.
So Jesus said, "My daughter, if I allowed them to hear something of what you say to me, it was because of their great faith.
And if I don't do it, I feel as if I was defrauding them.
But let others try, and you will see that I wouldn't even let utter a sound.
I want to give you Matthew 7.6. Don't throw your pearls before swine.
Matthew 7.6.
Jesus said, "I let some people know what's going on between you and me, because they'll benefit from it.
But there are others, and they won't benefit from it. I'm not going to shut them down."
And if you were reading all of this stuff by yourself, you'd find there are parts that you would get.
And the recommendation we'd give you is just keep going.
And when you go back, you might be ready for the bit that literally he shut your eyes when you were going through it.
So Louisa said, "I fear Jesus that even at this moment we're not alone," she said.
And if you allow things to get out, where will my obscurity in you be anymore?
Listen, Jesus, I'm telling you this nice and clear. How's that?
"I don't want my nonsense to get out," she said.
She must be laughing up in heaven.
"Because you alone know me how mad and bad I am," she said.
"For I even reach the point of being impertinent with you, and of being fussy as if I were a little girl."
"Who would ever reach this point? No one. Only my madness, my pride and my wickedness," she said.
"And since I see that you love me more," in other words, he likes it.
"In order to have more love from you, I continue with my nonsense, caring about nothing but to be your amusement."
"What do others know of this?" She said.
She's right because most people don't have any idea of a closeness to Jesus like this.
They know about a religious closeness, do you know what I mean?
In other words, that you say all the right things and you give all the right responses.
But not this family closeness, not this spousal closeness, which is absolutely incredible.
And he said, "My daughter, don't worry. I told you that I too don't want this habitually at most once in a hundred times."
That's why she's living, while she's living.
And almost to distract me, he said, "What do you want to say to those who are in heaven?"
That's interesting. And Louisa said, "By myself, I want to say nothing to anybody, only to you, I can say everything."
And through you, you will tell me that I regard and greet everyone, your sweet mother, your angels and the saints, my brothers and the virgins, my sisters and so on,
and tell them all to remember me, I'm poor, exiled one.
Now, he only asked her that to distract her, to know to be from what she was thinking.
So February the 2nd, how the victim's soul must be.
You can see the victim's souls have a very special place.
I'll probably be looking up for a few million miles at them.
This morning, as I offered a soul, this is a very interesting dialogue, I really enjoyed this.
Louisa is offering a soul as victim to Jesus. And Jesus accepted the offer. He has so few of them that if somebody is offering, he'll accept it, okay?
And he said to Jesus, "He said to Louisa, my daughter, the first thing I want is union of wills."
In other words, you've got to have union if you're going to be a victim's soul.
You can't be a victim's soul at a distance from union with God. It's not possible.
She must give herself prey to my will. She must be the amusement of my volition.
The way we would say that is fully surrendered to the divine will.
I will be very attentive on looking at whether everything she does is connected to my will, especially if it's voluntary.
Now, for the victim's soul, everything they do must be voluntary, that nobody is asking it of them, and God is not asking it of them as well.
They offer themselves as a victim, and they set up this connection between themselves and God.
So, in fact, I will not take into account things that are not voluntary to the point that when she tells me that she wants to be my victim, I will consider it as not said.
That's very interesting, isn't it?
Now, suffering that's not voluntary is something that's given to you by somebody else, and something maybe even as a result of decisions you've made yourself, the result of your own actions.
We say he or she is their own worst enemy, don't we?
Yeah, they're not voluntary.
A voluntary thing is that I choose to take the crown of Torrance and where.
I mean, Louisa does that all the time. I choose to do that in order to relieve the Lord of the suffering that he has and to mitigate chastisements on the earth.
Okay, so the whole thing is voluntary. That's the number one.
And if they're not into voluntary sufferings, Jesus said, "I won't even listen."
Now, number two, to the union of my will, add a victim of love. Now, St. Therese offered herself as a victim of love.
And I will be jealous of everything. True love is no longer master of itself but of the beloved.
So, if you offer yourself as a victim of love, then divine love takes over and you're not in control.
Third, she must be a victim of emulation. She must do everything in the attitude of sacrificing herself to me even in the most indifferent things.
That means 24/7, 365, emulating yourself.
To this, you will add that being a victim, you will add being a victim of reparation.
She must feel sorrow for everything. She must repair me for everything. She must sympathize with me in everything.
And there will be this fourth thing.
If she behaves faithfully in this, then I will be able to accept her as a victim of sacrifice, suffering, heroism and consummation.
Now, we've been through all of that with Louisa.
Recommend that she is faithful. And if she is faithful, everything is done.
Now, watch this. Louisa said, "Yes, she will be faithful." And Jesus said, "We'll see."
Guess who knows more about human nature? I just love the way he finishes that, we'll see.
Because many people start a race. Not everyone finishes it.
Okay, so let's come to February the 3rd, 1912. We're talking about purity and love.
"Continue in my usual state, my beloved Jesus came, and placing his holy hand under my chin, he told my daughter,
"You are the reflection of my glory." My goodness, if you said that to me, I'd faint.
Two Corinthians 3, 18. Two Corinthians 3, 18. That you become what you worship.
And then he added, "In the world I need mirrors in which to go and look at myself."
Now, this was introduced in Volume 1.
Now, this is what you find in these volumes that he will introduce something, he'll come back to it at a later point, and even at a later point again.
"I need mirrors," he said, "to which to go and look at myself.
"Only then can a found serve as a mirror in which people can reflect themselves when the found is pure."
Because, you know, a mirror, that's not clear. You don't really get it, do you?
But it's no use for the found to be pure if the waters are cloudy.
It's useless for that found to boast about the preciousness of the stones in which it is founded if the waters are cloudy.
"Nor can the sun make its rays perpendicular so as to render those waters silvery and communicate to them the variety of colors."
"Nor can people reflect themselves in it. My daughter, virgin souls, are the similes of the purity of the found."
Now, we're used to the idea of talking about virgins, meaning a person who is virgin in body.
They've had no sexual relationship with anybody.
The vast majority of people are not like that, but everybody can be a virgin soul.
A virgin soul is someone who loves God more than anything else.
The virgin soul is the one who has entered into the relationship with God and is seriously living the spiritual life.
They put God first.
And so the virgin souls are the ones who try to live due to our enemy six, four to ten, loving God with all your heart, soul, mind and being.
These are similes for the purity of the found.
The crystal clear and pure waters are the upright working that we would call that righteousness, this righteousness in a person's life.
And the sun that makes it raised perpendicular is me, the light of God.
And the variety of colors is love.
Therefore, if I do not find purity, righteousness and love in the soul, she cannot be my mirror.
By the same token, you know how to be a virgin soul.
That he finds purity, righteousness and love in the soul.
These are my mirrors in which I make my glory be reflected.
With all the others, even if they are virgins, that is in the body.
Not only can I not reflect myself, but if I wanted to do so, I couldn't recognize myself in them.
And the sign of all this is peace, that's Philippians 4, 7, the peace that passes all understanding and guards the heart and the mind in Christ Jesus.
And Isaiah 26, 3, you keep him in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you.
The sign of it all is peace.
So, you know, when you're studying these volumes and there's so much there, you might say to yourself, well I haven't to tell how I would sort of discern myself.
And the very simple thing is discern the level of peace that's there.
Because the peace goes deeper and deeper and Jesus keeps on saying, no matter what I've said, it all wraps up into peace, interior peace.
And the sign of all this is peace.
From this you will be able to know how very scarce are the mirrors that I have in the world.
In fact, very few are peaceful souls.
I've met so many people who have said to me, I've no peace of mind.
So many.
And you just say to yourself, where do we begin?
This one out, you know, and this peace in the depths of your being means you are in communion with God.
Okay.
So February the 10th, 1912, this one is about discernment and it's very important.
"Continue in my usual state," Louisa said, "my beloved Jesus made himself seen for just a little."
And he told me, "My daughter, when one leaves everything
and operates for me," now to leave everything means that you're stripped.
And stripped means that you remember volumes one to four, all the detachment from the world and from self and material things and all the rest of it.
Okay.
So when one leaves everything, now the biggest thing you leave is the self and selflessness and self-esteem and all the rest of it.
So you leave to cleave, do you remember?
So when you leave all of this and they operate for me, that means they work for the Lord.
And loves everything divinely, that means at a divine level, so that's in the divine will.
All things are at his disposal.
Isn't that very interesting?
He keeps on underlining all the time that spiritually the baggage allowance is very, very low.
Very low.
And the more you want to fly, the less baggage you can take.
It doesn't matter whether it's good, bad or indifferent baggage.
If it's baggage, you leave it and you keep going.
Okay. And then you want to be told as we go on in the volumes that the Lord wants to spiritualize us more and more and more.
And I'll explain on the 29th something I really discovered about our blessed mother that will explain Louisa as well.
That by the time you're ready to go, he has you spiritualized to the point that the soul just goes.
And without moving a feather or anything, you know, no movement on the outside, the soul just goes.
In other words, if I can use aviation language, lift off.
They're ready to go.
Yeah, it's fascinating.
But if you're more about that, okay.
He said the sign that one has left everything for me and has reached the point of operating and loving everything divinely is this.
That in operating speaking, praying and everything, he no longer finds hindrance, displeasure, contrast and opposition.
That's very interesting.
In other words, you move easily.
Isn't that interesting?
You no longer finds hindrances, the hindrances are in ourselves.
Only this very day I spoke to someone who was in one of my divine will classes years ago, years ago, years ago.
And I said, "How are you doing now?"
And she said, "Oh, I had an awful dispute with divine will."
She said, "There's no way I could go back."
She said, "If you're disputant, divine will, just settle the dispute and then come back."
But it wasn't hard to actually settle the dispute for her, which was very surprised.
I said, "This is the solution to what you're struggling with."
They're the hindrances and the displeasure.
There's something in it you just don't like.
That's the displeasure.
You've got to deal with the contrast, you know, the little oppositions and so on.
Because in the face of this power of operating and of loving everything divinely,
all lower their heads and dare not even breed.
In fact, I who am a benevolent father and always guarding the human heart,
that's your Philippians 4, 7 to 9, always guarding the human heart, Philippians 4, 7 to 9.
And in seeing it slip away from me, that is operating and loving humanly.
Now, notice that we are contrasting humanly with divinely.
Is that all right?
Sometimes in my book I will do that.
I will literally circle the word divinely and the word humanly
so that the next time you come back to see it, say, "That's the issue."
I'm saying that because you're in study groups.
Is that okay?
That there's the issue.
One is how you operate divinely and the other one is operating humanly.
So if they slip away from me and they're operating humanly,
she said, "I put thorns and displeasure and bitterness,
and they prick and embitter the human work and the love."
So what the Lord does is that He allows opposition to happen to you,
to get you to think again, the thorn, just pricks.
We call them the pinpricks of every day, don't we?
He allows that to make sure that you remember not to operate on a level that's too low.
And the soul, on seeing herself pricked, realizes that this way of hers is not divine,
so she enters into herself and acts differently.
So you can see that the little pinpricks of every day are there to go due to get back into...
It's like your car giving you dips and everything if you go very slightly towards the car,
because nowadays cars talk to you, you know?
In fact, He said the pricks are the sentinels of the human heart,
and they provide it with eyes to be able to see who the one is who is moving her,
whether it's God or human nature.
That's a very good piece, but you need to just read it nice and slowly for yourself,
because while we may think we're operating on a divine level,
you can sort of discover a few hours later that you've forgotten all about it.
You know what I mean?
Well, I've got to go back up again.
So on the other hand, that's a very Jewish expression on the one hand and on the other hand.
When the soul leaves everything and operates and loves everything divinely,
she enjoys my peace.
It's John 14, 27, and Luke 12, 51, John 14, 27, and Luke 12, 51.
She enjoys my peace.
And instead of having the sentinels and the eyes of the prickings,
she has the sentinel of peace.
That's what we said a few minutes ago.
The thermometer really is peace.
How much peace do I have?
Which moves anything that can disturb her peace away from her.
That's Hebrews 1320.
Hebrews 1320.
And the eyes of love which put to flight and burn those who want to disturb her.
Therefore, they remain at peace with regard to that soul.
And they give her peace and they place themselves at her disposal.
It seems that the soul can say, "Nobody touched me because I am divine."
Isn't that incredible?
So as Sam 82, 6, I said, "You are God's, all of you sons of the Most High."
Yeah, and it's also Sam 8, verse 5.
You've made us little less than a God with glory and honor your crown dust, okay?
Nobody dared to disturb my sweet rest in my highest good.
And if you dare dare to with the power of Jesus, which is mine in the divine will,
I'll put you to flight.
Now, in order to really get the whole of that message,
you have to kind of remember what was given in volumes 1 and 2, particularly.
And that is that Jesus said, "You mustn't have any disturbance.
You must deal with all kinds of disturbance.
You must make sure that there's self-denial and mortification in your life.
You must try and get your life right into the stream of divine will.
And then the peace will take over, the peace will take over.
And with the peace, you get spiritual security and so on and so on.
And so you get the same thing on a higher level here that you can either operate
divinely or operate humanly.
Now, outside of you, nobody's going to know that.
Absolutely nobody is going to know which level you're operating on, you know.
And just like if you're sitting in an airplane, you have no idea how the pilot is operating the controls.
You just hope for the best.
[laughter]
We had a very interesting experience some years ago in Europe
that made me lose all trust in pilots forever.
And that is that both pilots fell asleep on a flight across Europe.
And it was one of the air hostesses that picked up the warning sign,
walked the two fellas off in time.
Their problem was there wasn't enough wind to give them a wake.
And the rest of us don't want the wind.
That's amazing, isn't it?
Okay.
So that's volume 10 done.
So at least introduce you to volume 11 before we have a break
because then you'll realize what rich food you're coming into when you come back
after your holidays.
Volumes 11 and 12 are the roof on this building that we've been dealing with.
The foundations are volume 1 to 4.
You build the walls 5 to 10.
The roof is 11 and 12.
And then after that is all the decorations of the house.
It's really, really a fantastic thing.
So the richness of volume 11 is just absolutely...
Have you got volume 11 you have?
Okay. And the very first thing we begin with,
which is nice at the end of a class and why I want to do it.
Okay.
And I only want to do this bit and then give you your break.
It's her good night to Jesus and the blessed sacrament.
So it's a lovely way to finish a class.
It's not that I want to dive you into a new book in five minutes at the end.
It would give you this beautiful prayer.
So this is the very first thing in volume 11.
"Oh my Jesus, celestial prisoner," she said.
"The sun is now setting, the darkness invades the earth,
and you remain alone in the tabernacle of love."
I seem to see you with an air of sadness because of the loneliness of the night,
not having around you the crown of your sons and your tender spouses,
who may at least keep you company in your voluntary imprisonment, not as voluntary.
He's the divine victim.
"Oh my divine prisoner, I too feel my heart catch for having to leave you,
and I am forced to say goodbye to you."
But what am I saying?
Jesus, never again, goodbye.
I don't have the courage to leave you alone.
Goodbye is with my lips, but not with my heart.
Rather, I leave my heart with you in the tabernacle.
It's not a wonderful thing.
I will count your heartbeats and I will respond to them, not correspond,
but respond, or as, to them with my heartbeat of love.
I will number your panting size and to cheer you.
I will make you rest in my arms.
I will give you vigilant, I will be your vigilant century.
I will be attentive to see if anything comes to trouble you or to sudden you,
not only so to never leave you alone, but also to take part in all your pains.
Now, this prayer actually illustrates what we've been talking about at the end of Chapter 10,
and that is that the person who truly loves the Lord is thinking of Him all the time.
She's no longer thinking of herself.
O heart of my heart, O love of my love, leave this air of sadness and be consoled.
I don't have the heart to see you afflicted.
While with my lips I say goodbye, I leave with you my breaths, my affections,
my thoughts, my desires, and all my movements, which forming a chain of continuous acts of love
united to yours will surround you like a crown and will love you for all.
Aren't you happy, Jesus? It seems you say yes.
Goodbye, she said, no, she told me she wasn't good to say goodbye.
Goodbye, O loving prisoner, she said, but I haven't finished yet.
This is the Italian inner, you know.
Before I depart, I also want to leave my body before you.
I intend, notice the intention, placing the intention.
I intend to make of my flesh and of my bones many little pieces
in order to form as many lamps for as many tabernacles as exist in the world.
Say that if you mean it and if you don't skip it.
You have to be very honest with God. Is that okay?
And of my blood, she said, I want to make little flames to light those lamps.
And in every tabernacle, I intend to put my lamp,
which uniting with the lamp of the tabernacle that gives you light at night will say to you,
I love you, I adore you, I bless you, I repair you, and I thank you for me and for all.
Goodbye, O Jesus, but listen to one more word.
Let us make a pact and the pact be that we will love each other more.
Love never has enough, as you know.
You will give me more love and will enclose me in your love
and will make me live of love and will bury me in your love.
Now, that's Ephesians 3, Ephesians 3, 16-21.
Grounded in love and built on love and reaching the fullness of love.
Okay. And you will bury me in your love.
Let us tighten our bond of love more strongly.
I will be content only if you give me your love to be able to really love you.
Goodbye, O Jesus, bless me and bless all.
Class me to your heart and prison me in your love,
and I leave you placing a kiss on your heart.
Is that a nice way to finish it?
That's the only reason why I wanted to start while I'm 11 tonight.